Okay.
Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for being here.
On behalf of all a Lex Google
talks at and Latino Heritage La,
I'd like to welcome everyone to our first
Hispanic heritage month event or we're
going to have a panel discussion where
we celebrate the vibrancy of Latini that
or an on many different aspects
that make us Latino today.
We will hear it firsthand from three
very talented local Latino artists,
each one of them providing their own
take on what it means to be an artist in
the u s I will start with [inaudible]
in the middle son's I coordinate who is
the first generation Salvadorian
American artists born in Houston, Texas.
Historical collective memory of post
civil war Salvadorian culture is an
important influence and
inspiration for her work.
She recently implemented a
portfolio preparation course
at blessedly La Rasa for
students aspiring to
continue their education and
profession in the arts center.
Received a VFA from Vcu with a
concentration in painting and printmaking,
recipient of the Ellen
Battelle stoeckle fellowship.
She attended the Yale Norfolk summer
program. Thanks for being here
and then we have your land all the way
to the left or to your right was born
into a family who is artistic heritage
dates back to 1877 Gonzales's travels in
different countries.
The bonds forge the individuals in those
places and the resulting transformative
experiences are reflected in her art and
her life. She has done for her strong,
bold brushstrokes of color and texture
intent and evoke in imagination and
emotion.
She was an artist in residence in Ginza,
Japan followed by a similar stint in
Assisi, Italy. Throughout the years,
Gonzalez has started various
community organizations.
You can see some of her work on the gold
line trains as well as buses throughout
La.
In a collaboration with a Arp,
you'll end the study that the Pasadena
Art Center College of design after
winning a painting competition that
are awarded her a scholarship to the
prestigious school.
Thanks again of course,
and now we have Roselli Lopez Elo's
Angeles based artists whose work involved
combining cultural iconography with
references of our everyday surroundings.
At a young age, she was heavily
impacted with the realities of loss,
addictions and violence.
Within our immediate family,
which continue to shape our
perspectives and society and culture.
She primarily uses printmaking but
been picado installation and the altar
offering to really experiences of survival
loss in pride was a earned a master
of fine arts in printmaking from Indiana
University and do a bachelor of fine
arts degrees in graphic design and print
making from California State University.
Long Beach.
All three women have had their artwork
exhibited in many museums around the
country and internationally.
So let's give him a warm welcome.
[inaudible]
welcome to the Google fund maybe.
Yeah, this is very exciting.
Super exciting to do it.
You know,
Spanish heritage month first
event and we have you. Yeah.
So I'm super,
super excited to not only have you here
but also your artwork if you haven't
seen the fabulous display of art that
have here in the collection in the
boardwalk. Some people were
like, what is the boardwalk?
We have a in front of the Barista outside
of big Lebowski. That is our boardwalk.
That's where we have um,
six different artists displayed
and three of them are right here.
So I love to know.
So there was probably a thought
process which artwork bring to Google.
Was that hard?
Like we have like six for one side of
you specifically chose one Jolanda like
six Roselli four.
I'm very interested like the behind the
scenes look at why these pieces and what
the selection process was. So just so
everybody knows if we go to one slide,
this is your land does work.
Yolanda, tell us about this.
Why did you choose these very particular
pieces to have here with us today? Well,
they wanted to
um,
exhibit something contemporary,
something that was
representational of my work. Um,
that was more recent, that had, um,
all of the texture that I usually use a
color that is known for the Chicano Art.
Um,
and I wanted to send some of the
works that I'm most excited about. Oh,
very nice. Which are some
still lives and some portraits.
And these are portraits of people
that I know that are dear to me, uh,
that represent strength,
power,
positive energy and love.
Thank you.
And now the way the subject,
I noticed that two of the paintings
are called Deanna something.
Who is this DNR person?
Well,
the Ana Elise has a very dear
friend of mine and her husband is a,
an incredible, um, jewelry. My Sro,
so this is Diana's husband. This is all
of the work that he creates. And um,
we've known each other for about 25
years and she's just a brilliant woman.
Brilliant, powerful woman.
Great. That's so nice.
Do they have this artwork in their
homes? Uh, they do. They have some,
they have a house in the loom and they've
taken some portraits that I've created
of them to their home.
Oh, that's wonderful. Thank you. Thank
you. And then in the next page, um,
we have Roselli's work.
Roselli,
you have four different pieces here
with poppin picado and different things.
Tell us why these specific pieces,
uh,
kind of going off what Yolanda was saying,
I wanted to pick work that exemplified,
uh, when I'm creating right now, um,
as a printmaker and someone who
combines that with [inaudible].
I wanted to choose works
that talk about the,
a friend that and offering and,
um,
a very contemporary way in an
untraditional somewhat ways. So,
um, I have a puppet picado
piece of an La scene, um,
a family portrait that I
combined with led lights and, um,
a couple other, uh, offering that
pieces that are all puppet Ricardo.
So I felt like together they make a
group being that really talks about, um,
the things that I feel embody
the content that I work with.
That's great. Thank you.
Yeah. So you do a lot.
So you do these also tons of
other like, cause you, yeah.
Combine you installation art.
Um,
sometimes it's just pure printmaking mixed
together sometimes with Buckin picado
so I really enjoy creating,
transforming spaces to give
people an experience. So, um,
sometimes that means breaking out of the
frame and, and uh, inhabiting a space. So.
Nice.
Thank you.
That's great.
And now we're going to see standards
work and Sandra is very specific.
You have like this big huge artworks.
One P one.
I'm very curious why one
one piece? Well, it's, it's a group
of work that I'm currently working on.
I tend to work in series,
um, set the moment.
I'm exploring notions of childhood,
um,
memory and nostalgia. Like, what
drives that nostalgic power,
um, in this image is, you know, is it
something that's been romanticized,
something that's been skewed?
Like why, why, like what does,
like why does it have that power?
So I love kind of like asking these
questions as I'm making the work.
So as you see this piece,
it's representational yet has
very abstract elements to it.
So kind of like a push and pool,
like an inquiry of my past,
like where I come from. Um, so it's
a very tender, loving memory. Um,
you know,
that's a bit like this combobulated and
may make sense and it might ring truth
to some, some of my viewers. I hope so.
No,
I loved it.
So all the work is beautiful and I
thought it was very powerful that you just
chose one. Yeah. Like this
is, I need to know more. Um,
so I like to know also,
um,
so you were talking about themes and how
right now you're working on this theme
of like childhood. Yeah. What drives a
theme? Like when, for all three of you,
when you work on a theme,
what is that driver or that
influence to go on that theme?
How do you choose the theme that is next?
Well,
there tends to be themes that I've been
working with for a really long time.
So whether it's commemorating a, a
figure, like in a monolithic space,
like one figure in a space.
Like why, like telling a story,
like always very narrative.
Like I'm so childhood social
justice where I'm from El Salvador,
like it's history,
so it's very historically based and
I'm always seeking out a narrative and
whatever that narrative may be,
that's the image that surfaces so great.
Yeah.
Um, how, how does it work for both of you?
I think for myself it's something
that's very personal and um,
I try to cover narratives that are,
um,
what people are going through along with
myself and that reality and how that
reality is portrayed on canvas,
uh, in a beautiful manner.
Thank you.
In my case, I feel like I'm
very much, I'm inspired by, um,
my community, my neighborhood. And um,
in the beginning a lot of my work was
definitely influenced by those worth those
alters and how women would use these
alters as a platform to discuss social
issues in the community as a way to have
a voice and gathering assemblage work.
And so, um, from that and
using my own experiences, I,
I use it as a way to
talk about people who I want to praise
or I want to commemorate and how we can
take pride in our communal histories and
stories and display them as something
to be very proud about.
Nice.
Do you feel that, so of course, I
mean artwork is, is your emotion.
There's a lot of,
there's a voice behind it.
And do you feel there's a voice or an
emotion that you tap into and when you do
better work comes out, what does that, so
people are like, I need to be depressed,
or Oh, I'm not an artist.
Like this is magical.
Do little things for my children, but
not, but, or certainly like in school,
but now tell me, how does that
work for you? That process?
No, definitely like for
me, like in my works,
the struggle, like a struggle,
any struggle. Um, uh,
perseverance, overcoming, um, beauty,
like all of these,
like very strong,
like elements that just run through
all of my work is what drives it.
Like,
absolutely.
Um, I definitely feel like
I'm in, in my case the,
the materials that I use and uh,
the person that I'm dedicating it to are
things that I harness and I want that
energy to transmute and
infuse into the artwork. Um,
so I pull on a lot of
those emotions a lot.
Most of the people I use are people
that I'm connected to in some way.
So I have a relationship
with them and I'm,
if I'm commemorating a past memory or
igniting a thoughts from other viewers in
it, I want them to, to cherish
those things and to have value, um,
so that they don't forget.
I know.
Okay. I think my inspiration is
people, the relationships that we have.
And then we'll watch shows that they
evoke in my soul and in my heart.
So when there's somebody
that I'm passionate about
that I'm creating a portrait
of, you definitely see it on the
canvas course. Absolutely. Yeah.
So, so, so it's that emotion that
we're discussing, right? So it's, yeah.
So when you're doing people, I mean
it's people you're passionate about it,
very excited to evoke.
Um,
is it just all pure happiness or do you
have like inner emotions that are coming
out in this painting too that
you're trying to get? I mean,
like there's always like subliminal
messages. Yeah. That too.
There's all kinds of emotions that,
that transpire in the creative process.
And it's that relationship
between your canvas. Um,
and since I've been painting for 30 years,
it's,
it's a love relationship and it's
this medium that feeds my soul and um,
and then this other person. So it's
a dialogue between the three of us,
between the creative process, the
canvas, myself and the sitter,
the portrait I'm creating of.
Um,
and so definitely there's different
emotions that come out and,
and it's lovely to allow yourself to
convey that with the brush strokes.
Sure. Definitely. Yeah.
So tell me,
tell me,
I was just going to say it's like a form
of communicate. Instead of using words,
you can say it basket with
images and yeah. And textures.
And as those things layer,
it creates the emotion that you're
not quite able to put into the same,
same sort of wording. So it, um,
you hope that people get that when
they see it or it allows them to see
something in a different way because
that's how you find your mode of
communication happening best. Sure. Yeah.
That's like for the next Google talk,
we'll just have easels. Absolutely.
Great idea that's doing it.
Um,
so I'm very proud to be a amongst,
you know, all these Latinas. Right?
It's wonderful. And I'm thinking, how
hard is it? I mean, I Latina a woman,
basically you're an entrepreneur,
right?
How hard is it in the art world to be
a Latina and a woman, you know, in,
in, in a business that's, there's
a lot of men in it to tell me,
I want to know.
Um,
there are obstacles.
I tend to not focus on them.
I just continued to forge forward and
to continue to be focused on what I'm
doing in business and my creativity.
So there'd Yolanda Gonzales who
is the artist, the creative, um,
and there is your land.
They go on sale as the business person
that was taught to me by my dad,
the Apollo one, Silas who
was a great businessman. Um,
so I think if you can separate yourself
from the creative and then to the
business of this, this
beautiful painting, um,
that you're going to hand over, their
soul is going to hang in somebody's home.
I think it's important to focus on that.
So there are obstacles,
but I think like in any, in
any other line of work, um,
I just focus on a clear,
straight and narrow road.
That's to my goal.
It's that Latino backbone.
And we have parents and family
who teaches how to work hard,
show us what it's like to have
dedication into something.
And, um, I, I feel like I definitely
pull from that to like my mom,
single parent mom and what
she did to make things work.
And you use that transmute that into what
goals you want to accomplish. And it,
it sets,
it comes through.
You can tell people's drive and
you could see it because they,
they learned from people before and
them not even in the same field or a
different thing,
but they see it being applied and
then it trickles down into your own
personality and the way that you, that
way that you meet that you work. Sure. So,
um, uh, I think that there
is definitely a struggle.
Being an artist is not easy.
And I,
I want to do a lot of
answers first because she's,
she's got a lot more experienced than a,
Sandra and I were,
were newer in this starting
game. So I feel like, uh,
I learned from women like her that,
that their strength and their, um,
passageways. Then pioneering
these these paths for us. Yeah.
Make it a different world for us than
it was, I think even in their timeframe.
So I acknowledged that.
I really feel like they are people that
I like to look up to and I learned from,
um, I'm a teacher too. So I feel
like as an instructor, as a teacher,
sometimes a student has don't think like,
Oh, where's the teacher? Oh, that's me.
You know what is right here.
I'm not as a,
I appreciate her boldness
and her strength.
And I think that's something that
I really admire about Yolanda.
It comes through in her work and,
um, I feel like, uh, I'm just,
I'm coming to my own in that,
um,
I'm finding that voice and I'm
figuring how that communicates with my
surroundings and my neighborhood.
Um, I feel like I can be a, uh,
a venue for communicating
these things. Um, how,
how I am impacted by them and how
other people see this happening in our
communities.
So we play an important role in showing
people that it's not the same route to
understanding what's happening in our
culture, in our neighborhood. And,
um, I, I feel thankful to be a
part of events like this because,
um,
it's not a voice that's commonly heard.
It's not a voice where we often get
a platform to be such a strong voice.
So I appreciate, um,
being involved with it
then being involved with artists like,
like these. So of course. Are you kidding?
You're always welcome. Yeah. I'd like
to say thank you for saying that.
I appreciate it and I've, um, I've
worked hard to, to keep it, um,
my reputation and my persona kind of a,
a certain way for,
for you.
The aura comes through. I never
had, I never had the kids, you know,
I never had a kid.
Yeah.
But I felt when I would go places, I
always tell my friends we're representing,
we are representing, we're
responsible wherever we are, you know,
we are responsible to hold
up who we are and our,
our whole culture where there were the
only Chicana in the room at its function
in a very astute place. And
we're representing, of course,
it doesn't matter if you're in the
restroom or if you're in the dining room.
People Watch and you have to represent
who you are, who your culture is.
Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. And
Los Angeles, just in general,
like I've moved around a bit and
I've experienced different, um,
like art communities.
But having,
having arrived here three years ago,
I found a lot like an art community
here that was just very inviting,
very giving, like, you know, finding
these strongholds. Like he's beautiful,
powerful women, like Chicana
artists that, you know,
that'll give you a chance. Like, you know,
I'm, I'm Salvadorian, but I met this, uh,
amazing artists, Margaret Garcia when
I first moved here and she's like,
oh honey,
we're all the same here.
Like within like a week
of me having meeting her,
like she already had me kind of like
meeting different people and into
exhibitions and it's just like everyone
here is like down to help each other out,
which is something that you don't
really find in a lot of places.
So it's a lot of power here within the
art community and Chicanas Latinas in
general.
So you're paying it forward. You
were saying you, you know, you're,
you always have a voice. You always,
people are always watching. Do you mentor,
tell us a little bit about that.
Like what do you do to like pip?
So to give to the next generation?
Cause I know your team right
now. I, I I love teaching.
I teach right now at two
cal state universities at
cal State Long Beach and cal
state North Ridge and also at Cerritos
College. So, um, teaching art.
I feel like some of my
biggest mentors that I have,
a lot of them were professors and some
of them were working artists outside of
the institution.
So I really try to bring,
I try to think about how I can
bring that communal experience and,
and working with artists outside of
the institution and think about how you
could bring that into the institution
and work with students and get them to
clarify their own voices, how you're
teaching them, how to use a medium,
and then also how to speak
through that medium. So, um,
it's an interesting thing. I think like
that helps to pay it back. I think. Uh,
I'm really happy to also work at
the community level with places like
[inaudible] where I get to work with
youth and those young kids that just love,
you know, working with art. It's not
even always about the end product.
It's about the process of working
and having fun and you know,
those experiences coming together
or what makes it a lot of fun.
So yeah, of course. Anything
over there I have more questions.
You know, I think, I think it's
important to, um, mentor. Um,
I've taught several places throughout
the 30 years that I've been creating art.
I worked for blessing for
plastic Rasa teaching, um,
and for better Los Ninos, uh, for
inner city yards for 14 years. Um,
and it was amazing to work
with the youth and, um,
just to teach them art, but to also
teach them acceptance of who they are.
Right now I work with ultimate,
uh, teaching senior citizens,
teaching senior citizens a
watercolor and a ceramics,
hence your arp. Yes. And they're
absolutely, and they're absolutely lovely.
Absolutely lovely.
And so you were here recently,
you're saying three years
ago, right? Yeah. So how,
how,
so they've embraced you and now it's too
early to move to give back or what are
you, what are you thinking about in terms
of like the next generation? How, um,
Oh man,
I'm, I'm excited to be working
with Walesa La Raza. I was, um,
I noticed that while I was working for
Margaret Garcia and I also worked for
Frank Romero and other
artists in the community, um,
I would assist them within their classes
at Plaza La Raza and realize that there
was really nothing being offered for the
next generation that's trying to move
forward and kind of like
hone in on their skills,
what they're really trying to say and
express and just like start developing
their own style, their
own voice through art. Um,
so I proposed a portfolio preparation
course at blessed and we're entering the
fourth semester now. So I'm
pretty excited about it. I,
we have many beautiful,
very talented artists and just giving
them a space to really think about the
work that they're making and have
them develop their style. Um,
that was something that was very
important for me as a kid in high school.
Like having that teacher that,
you know,
we'll just kind of give you the space
and room to do what you need to do. Um,
and you know,
and just like beginning dialogue,
like having conversations about your work.
Like there's more to it than just the
beautiful image, you know, or, um,
so that's,
I already feel like I'm,
I'm giving into that and feeding it and,
and it's feeding me as well.
It's definitely like a
reciprocal relationship.
I love it. So I mean, as an artist,
I mean your surrounding shape,
you and,
and you know and influence you and the
people you meet and all the travels that
you do. I mean, you've moved around,
you've traveled, you've been to, you know,
even done work in a CC.
Um,
you've had a ton of things also in
the community had happened. You know,
if there's a lot that
goes on, um, in my mind,
can you think of an anecdote or a story
or like one example that's really shows
they wanted piece of art really
made an impact. Is there like a,
like the one or is it like, no all
the time or everything? I don't know.
I mean, when and why, what
is, what made that impact?
Aw, I guess during, yeah,
you got a story. I love it.
Uh, I, I've had this idea of why I would
make a lot of altars and a lot of, uh,
offerings.
So it,
I've had this idea for a long time and
I was happy to be able to do it finally,
like I think three years into having it
was in my sketchbook and I finally get
to do it and that's the
grant money to do it. Um,
but I've always wanted to do
this popup alter installation.
I'm dedicated to my mom. My
mom, when she passed away,
we inherited all of her plants.
And so my sister and I started taking
care of her plants and learning how to
have this green thumb because we wanted
to preserve her through these plants.
And so I've been sprouting them and my
sister and I were living together and
then we were going to part ways.
She was going to get a job somewhere else.
And the thought of not having her
plants was like, oh, don't worry,
I'm going to clone them. I'm going
to, we can each have, you know.
So I cloned all the plants and I started
getting into cloning and I decided to
make,
I wanted to make a pop up alter where
people shared stories of their mother's
with me and an exchange.
I would give them a sprouting
Platt from one of my mom's plants.
So I wanted to gather and archive all
these and post them up on social media and
on my website so that people can listen
to these great stories that they told
and they share it about women in their
lives. So, um, this past mother's Day,
the day before mother's Day,
um,
I was able to set up a little popup
on the La River bed and I asked,
I got a chance to do it,
sit at this huge altar,
beautiful green plants and you know,
just seeing them sort of perky and happy
there. The plants that is, I always like,
like this is for you mom.
And then also hearing everyone's stories
of how women in their lives brought
like so much strength and um,
the amazing things that people remember
and also their connection to this living
thing, a plant, what that meant to a lot
of people. And those stories that I heard,
it was like a constant,
I felt like that was giving back because
those memories stay with people for the
rest of the day. They, they remember that
memory about grandma or about anti and,
and it stays with them and they thought,
man, I almost forgot about that.
And is because of that moment,
that event that they got to remember.
And that's what was really important
for me. I felt like that was,
that was my anecdote. That was
beautiful. Thank you. Wow. Yeah.
Are you going to do it again? Oh, I'd
love to. I've always wanted to do this,
like in a flea market or swap meet and
have a different sort of crowd, you know,
uh,
and then grow that archive and just
continue adding stories and adding stories
to it. So now you can,
not all of us. Yeah.
Sunday you had a story as well.
All you can tell, Huh? Yes.
Um,
so when I recently moved here,
this is why I think it's
just like when I moved here,
all the stars were just
like telling me like,
you're at the right place at the right
time. Uh, when I had just moved here,
um, I, I was, I remember I was in Home
Depot and I was like walking around.
I was like, well, I need a plant
from my new home, you know,
like looking around and then I
get an unknown phone call. Um,
and when I pick up,
I Maria,
what Datto is on the other line
at the other end of the line,
and I'm not sure if you
guys are familiar with her,
but she was very prominent.
Um,
social justice figure here in Los Angeles,
um,
had survived through many,
many things.
I'm in El Salvador and resettled
in the United States, um,
during the 80s.
So since the 80s,
she's been organizing with
so many different groups. Um,
she heard about the type of
work that I was doing, a,
which is all based on historical
collective memory, um,
like stories from the Salvadoran
civil war. And she said to me like,
I'd love to meet you and you know,
I'd love to talk to you. I'd love,
I'd love to have you paint me
like have a sitting, right?
So we talked about getting that together
and I worked with her for about a year
and walked away from the experience
with two really beautiful paintings.
But throughout that, that timespan,
like she shared her stories with me. Uh,
we would go out for
pool, we would, you know,
it's just a lot of beautiful
experiences. But, um,
she also sat me down to watch a
documentary that was done for her.
So we like sat in a room held hands
sometimes because it was just like the
story. It was just really intense. Um,
but she explained to me maybe midway of
having spent time with her that she had
cancer,
like you had come back and she had
a certain amount of time to live.
So just having the opportunity to sit
with her and paint her and share her
story, um, and exhibited
in different spaces,
like brought so many people together
from different parts of her life,
um, that would recognize that
person in the painting. Like
people were, you know, I,
I walked up to one person, I'm
a patron of mine actually. Uh,
and she was crying when
she was seeing the,
the painting and she shared with me
like once Maria had already passed,
she had shared the stories that they
shared together, like through goddess.
And so,
um,
I feel like it was just a very organic
and natural thing that just happened.
And I feel fortunate to have
been able to document that.
And so just produce something
that keeps her memory like living.
So it was pretty magical. Yeah. I'd
love to show you guys the images now,
but um, you know, but her story was,
was definitely about survival.
There's a beauty to it,
but there was also a lot of darkness
to it. Um, so I think, yeah,
it was just very powerful,
like for sharing of course.
Delanda all your experience.
Tell me one maybe,
I don't know,
then you can you reduce it? I
don't know. Yeah, I could, I can
reduce it. I think, I think
one that is very recent. Dom,
I was recently commissioned,
um, by ultimate to create a, um,
a sculpture for one of their
facilities. Um, and um,
I have been creating ceramics
for about 20 years. Um,
and um,
there are these women that I make that
are called the [inaudible] and they have
these Jong Ethos and they're very
colorful and very strong, uh, women.
Um,
so they asked me to create this piece,
which was going to end up being
about six feet tall and ceramics.
So I started to created,
um,
we had the heads that are large orbs
about this big. Um, we created the heads,
the torso and the skirt. Uh, and
it's during a time where, uh,
I was going through a very, um,
difficult a transition in my life.
And, uh, so we created the skirt,
which is about this tall am
and it's going into the, uh,
Kim and it breaks,
uh,
and it was very symbolic of
what I was going through.
We created another one and went into the
kiln. When it came out, it was cracked.
Um, then we created a third
and when it came out and,
and some form,
I was in a stronger place and kind of
more comfortable where I was and wasn't
struggling so much with the transition.
She came out fine.
And how long was that process between
the first one? It's been six months.
It was six months. Um, and then also
creating the orbs in the heads for me,
uh, was very organic and feeling
these orbs and creating the portrait.
Um,
I felt it was like,
this is what it would be like to give
birth this or I felt it and it was cool.
And the clay was,
the smell of the clay was just
so beautiful and magical. Um,
so I created her, it took four men to
install, or cause she's about 600 pounds.
Uh, she was installed. Um,
and so once she was installed and I
turned around and I looked at her,
I cried because I thought we have both
a completed this process together.
And that's what that piece was for me.
It was,
it was building myself up again to
continue what I had to continue.
Universal,
very symbolic and wow.
And so is there anything that I know
like transitioning from that, it's like
cry. It's an artist. Artist's
life. Welcome to the artist's life.
So in this roller coaster of emotions,
is there anything you were
Gret then? Nothing. Not One.
Is there a some type of artwork or,
um,
John Ra that you would never do?
Oh Wow.
Can't say that, but I dunno. I
Dunno. I'm asking you to say never.
We have so much that you wouldn't want
to wear that you're like have fear of,
is there like a, like a thing that
you're like, ah, I try to avoid it?
Mm.
I think if there's different mediums
because people will come to you. Um,
I was sent to Japan to do printmaking
and I had done some printmaking it self
help graphics,
but not that much.
But what you do is you
essentially, um, interpret it,
that style, that medium
in your process. Okay.
So you make it your own. Yes. And
then therefore it's accepting to you,
but is there anything else that
you were like, I don't know.
I don't want to go there.
It's not something that's
my style. I don't want to,
you know, maybe I,
yeah,
that's an interesting question.
Um, it's hard, I think, um,
when I think about moments in my life
where I wondered if I had gone this way
versus that way, I definitely
thought about, um, there,
there was a time in my life when I had
just graduated and I got my on my BFA
degree and I was going to be
going into Grad school. Um,
and there was a time in
between then when I, uh,
I lost my brother unexpectedly at
a very young age. Um, and he, um,
yeah,
he,
he died of an overdose and I was like
really distraught and my family was out of
state and I was in California.
I stayed here in California.
They had moved away and I really felt
like I wanted to be with them and it was
so difficult.
But here I am in a part of my life where
I'm supposed to decide where out of
state I'm going to school.
And it was a horrible feeling that
should have been like much different.
And so I, my heart wanted to go
to New Mexico where my family was.
And uh,
I had gotten a opportunity to go to Grad
school on a full ride scholarship in
Indiana University and the thought
of going across the country,
leaving Los Angeles and going
to a place where you know,
where you really are different.
Sure. Um, and it was, uh,
it was heart wrenching.
It was my mom's advice that sort of
pushed me into continuing to go into that
route because it was like, that's,
that's what he would wanted you to do.
But it wasn't what I wanted to do.
I wanted to go and meet with them.
So I wonder what my life would be
like if I had continued and lived out,
I dunno,
maybe applied to school out there and
decided to go a different route with my
life. Um, but while I was in Indiana,
I totally got immersed in like
an in using Altrisk as a way to,
to remember to heal and, um, to,
to learn to have my own voice.
So,
and having living in
that place where I there,
there's not as much social
diversity is we have in Los Angeles.
It really forced me to have to talk
about my work to people who didn't
understand it. So it was great. Yeah.
That experience was very difficult,
but also like, I think that, um,
yeah, it just was a point
in my life where I thought,
I wonder how it would have ended up if
I had gone somewhere else versus here.
Course. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Speechless a bit. Um,
very strong women. Wow.
I love all these stories and thank
you. They were very personal. Yeah.
Very thankful that you're
sharing that with us.
So it feels like I'm part of like,
I'm in your homes and you're like,
I need to give you some coffee, see
doors. And I'm like, this is like really
getting in touch with this beautiful
stories and like, wow. Thank you. Wow.
Um, okay. So, so I want to touch
a little bit more on the whole,
the whole aspect that you, you were
just, you were just touching on,
have you had to explain your art?
People really didn't get it or didn't
understand it. How was that process like,
have you had that experience too?
It was, I'm going to speak as a, you know,
acknowledging the fact that I'm
very young in this environment. Um,
but that I looked, it made me realize how
much more I had to study and learn, um,
the artists who are working in this
form before me and understand their
conversations and where it was coming
because it helped me build up my strength
to even be able to communicate
these things. I want to,
I want to talk about a person's life
and celebrate it without feeling the
drabness of death and like leaving this
life and I want to celebrate them and
the lessons that they taught
me and how do I do that? And,
and those Muertos and alters
and [inaudible] gave me
that venue to be able to
talk about it. So I, I
studied, I researched, I,
um,
I definitely wanted to investigate a lot
of Chicanos who were using alters as a,
as another way, not just to
commemorate their, aren't the silos,
but as a way to talk about the social
dynamics of where they're coming from and,
and how they can communicate
that in a public atmosphere.
It doesn't have to be in a, a white wall
gallery. It can be in, in a public space.
So, um, growing up in,
in La and having places like self help
graphics that are pioneering, you know,
a contemporary that was worth as a Chicano
wise version of it goes mirth though.
So it was like a setting
the pathway for me to,
to discuss all of these things and to,
to be who I wanted to be and talk about
my family and also my situation and
related to everyone else
around me. And uh, the,
even though I was all the way in Indiana,
I had the access to resources
to do this homework to, to,
to look at books and to read and research.
So when I came back home I felt like a
lot more empowered to understand it when
you kind of take it for granted a
little bit growing up in it. So yeah,
that's great.
And your power at a ton of other
people and now they're more educated,
empowered everyone here.
Yeah. Like it's more than just like a
lack as a makeup and you know, it's not,
forget this like,
yeah, of course. Thank you.
Sunday we were going to say anything.
No, maybe, but I do have a question.
So we were discussing, you know,
this voice that you have as artists.
How has social media or digital
or technology helped your careers
or not? I mean maybe not. Well,
I mean it helps in the sense of like
having you connected with so many of your
peers and your colleagues.
And I mean,
being able to research and especially
like the way that I gather like source
material. Um, it's very, you know,
I very much needed the Internet and
social media to be able to do that.
Um,
but in particular maybe,
I don't know, maybe not.
Yeah, I'm very intrigued by the,
um, the, the fact that, you know,
art is now accessible to all right.
So the minute you do something,
it is seen by millions and millions
of ball eyeballs all over the world
instantly.
And so when you're making this now,
cause it's different like
maybe even 30 years ago, right?
Oh yeah. I mean, when you're creating
[inaudible] excited about beepers,
well your [inaudible]
turn it around eight,
three, eight, three. It's love.
It's one, four, three, one,
four, three. I was there too.
I remember the phones,
the long cords.
Yeah.
I have a question for you then. So in the
30 year span you've, you've gone from,
you didn't have digital really to now
having people see or artwork if they want
it to around the world.
Does it change now your
perspective when you're painting a,
in the sense that before
people would go and you know,
wherever you had the exhibition
people would see it, you know,
it was that specific people maybe
you toward whatever it is you,
those are the people who saw
it. Right? We Seeked it out,
but now anybody can see it and share it.
Does that change how you paint now and
the voice or the message you want to
give?
Um, I think it changes a lot of things
except for the way I paint. Okay.
Because the painting process and my
relationship with the creative process,
um, is very pure to me. It's very sacred.
And so that is very strong.
One of the strongest relationships I have.
Um, and, but it's very exciting to me to,
um, to share. And I,
what I like to do is put a piece,
when I first start the sketch,
the rough,
when it's almost done and then when it's
completed so people can kind of see the
process of what's happening
of creation. So be it. Um,
so you know, when people put
their kids pictures every month
on Facebook and I put my paintings every
month, you know, both of my babies.
But that's what's exciting about it.
It's like we get to see like the studio
practice unfurled in front of us on
Instagram and Facebook. So
it's like that they, we,
and it's also hard to get used to it,
to opening people up to that process.
You know, how much do you want to show?
Like how much is exposed, you know,
like you want to keep
some of those things,
right? Yeah. Right. Yeah. It's
whatever you're comfortable with.
You know what I mean?
It's whatever you're comfortable really
sharing because it's out there and once
it's out there,
it's out there.
But it is amazing and I've
utilized it to the fullest where,
um, you know, you send out
your message, you know,
and you send out your images and then
you represent messages that need to be
represented as well. Um,
but I think it's, it's,
it's a fascinating, fascinating
process. You know, the Internet,
it's just fascinating to me and I'm,
I'm such a gadget person.
I love, I loved that. So anything I can
get my little hands on and, and, um,
expose people to what's going on
or in my world, my little utopian,
strange world that's there,
right? It's a, uh, it's exciting.
I feel like we're living in a world
where there's all kinds of new technology
happening all the time. And, uh,
as artists we get to figure out how to
interpret that and use that. And um,
so like a print maker and it's one of
those like classic dying forms that people
don't like to use any more
because it's very cumbersome.
But there's always this like conversation
on how we're pulling from new
technology to influence our work.
So how do we keep it relevant in this
of like constant technology of grades,
you know? So, um, I like
to see how it impacts the,
the conversation I want to have or the
way I envisioned a piece happening. Um,
there's some of the ways that I've
used is I'm a graphic designer,
so a lot of the work also starts off on
the computer using digital programs are
digitizing the work somehow.
And then I'm like,
it's seeing how the work can transmute.
I've had a chance to use CNC router
machines to create like custom furniture
pieces that are reminiscent
of my purple Picabo patterns.
And that was amazing experience.
Or like laser cutting machines.
I take puppet and Ricardo
and a whole other world.
What happens when the machine cuts it
out and he had these little burned edges
and you know, how those things start
to impact the, the message. And I just,
I'd be excited to be able to,
to play with it even more. Um,
I think what becomes a biggest
attorneys accessibility. It's expensive.
It's hard to get access to. So, um,
especially once you're outside and you
don't have access to like a university or
anything like that. How do you,
how do you use this equipment, um,
in your work? So, um,
yeah, I'd be excited to,
to try to learn to use it more and uh,
it's,
it provides another way for
you to have that communication.
So any other way that I can try to use a
technology and I've used it for sharing
the stories and I'm collecting to have
this online archive for an online alter.
Um, so I, I try to use it as much
as possible, but I think that,
um,
there's also some deterrent because of
the accessibility of it too. Of course.
Yeah. Yeah. The big machines
are talking about too. I mean,
just in how they collide though,
how you can take the old school in the
classic with like the new technology. So,
and there's like three d printers now
too. Yeah, yeah. Three d printing.
I'd love to, to mess around with that
kind of machinery. Yeah. Nice. Well,
so now I'm going to open it
up to the audience as well.
You have any questions at all please.
This is your time to, um, there's the,
uh, microphone, neither one.
We were talking about the one
you can throw around cube.
Anybody have questions?
Yeah.
Hi everyone. My name is
Eric. So first of all,
thank you guys for spending
an afternoon with us.
I thought this was really interesting
and really awesome and I'm really happy
that you guys came by. Uh,
so now my question is, uh,
a few months ago there was like a,
um,
a case in Canada where a
rider was criticized for
saying that other writers and
artists should take and write from the
point of view of different ethnicities,
cultures, genders, and backgrounds.
And so I was kind of curious
to hear what you guys thought.
If you would encourage others to sort
of take the point of view of people that
come from different
backgrounds that they do.
I think that's a big
responsibility. It is. Yeah.
I only have my own view and
I can't expect everybody to,
to respect,
um, or accept my point of
view on a whole of a culture.
I don't know at this need. I don't
think that's, I mean, it's right.
I think any artist out there
that's making work, I mean,
they're true aspiration should be to
convey a truly honest perspective of their
own. So I feel like being
able to share that, I mean,
that's how other people are
able to learn about it. Right?
But to put yourself in a different
place, it's, it's, it gets tricky.
Of course,
you don't want to be put in a position
where you're the spokesperson for
everyone and that just doesn't seem fair.
It's important to be inclusive,
to be aware, um, but to, to
be put in the position of,
you know, I'm the spokesperson for Latinos
and I would never want that. You know,
that responsibility is too many, too many
voices out there to be heard. So yeah,
that's, that's a pretty
tough criticism. Yeah.
So that's what a lot of
hard work. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
definitely. And I mean, I
completely agree. Like it's, I mean,
there's the variety of opinions
about it, I guess. Um, and you know,
like on one side, you know, you
should say like, oh, you know,
if by encouraging people to talk about
cultures that are different than their
own, you encourage them to, uh, find
commonalities to find ways to, to,
to empathize. And then from
the other point of view,
kind of like you said, it's,
well, there are many people that could
talk about this particular experience.
So why is somebody that may not have
as much experience or knowledge in that
background take it upon themselves
to, to talk about it. Um,
so I was kinda curious to hear what
you guys thought. So thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
So
cool
ladies,
thank you so much for being here and
I want to take it to the business
perspective.
Um,
women traditionally make 72
cents of the dollar of males.
Um,
black women make 62 cents
and Latinos even less.
So I'm wondering, in terms of
your male counterparts as artists,
when you're comparing art to art,
um,
do you find yourself having to or not
making as much as men do in the industry?
Why did we choose to
price it less than that?
What know are people wanting you to
charge you less because you're women or
Latinas?
That's interesting.
I've seen that on both ends of the
different artists I've worked with since
being in Los Angeles.
Like the more, you know,
like the more recognize like
male figure and you know,
a woman that's been like struggling and
really putting in the work like since
she began like decades
ago, you know, and uh,
just realizing like that there's,
that like women tend to kind of
like underprice their work or like,
like I don't, it's, it is, it's difficult
I think,
uh,
as a woman artist, it's, um,
it's important not to under price my work,
um,
to value my work for the years that I've
been creating art and it's been 30 long
years.
Um,
and I think it's a huge
responsibility for the artists,
the young artists who are following
me to open the door for them,
not only through my art,
but through my business sense.
So you educate people to pay.
If they want a piece of your art,
they want piece of your soul,
they're paying for it.
Yeah.
Properly. And if they don't buy it at
that price and they don't deserve it,
they don't buy at that price,
somebody else will, you know,
and I have little little pieces you
can get a little piece about this big,
we could take pat home.
That'll be fine. Nice.
I got it. Yeah. You
just got know your yeah.
Worth it. Like, you know, stick to it.
And it's hard because a lot of
artists are not business people.
I see here it's difficult to separate
because you're emotionally involved to
this,
this piece of art.
But then what you do is you find somebody
who you trust to represent your art
and, and to market it
that way. Yeah. Yeah.
I,
I struggle with that a
lot as well because I,
okay.
I worry about accessibility and I think
that when like all those things are
true, uh, pricing and the time,
that's an end, what you've invested,
where your career is at, all of those
things that factor into pricing.
And then some of the things I worry
about is like, who can buy that?
Who is going to be able to buy that?
Who am I making it for? And, um,
even though I know it's not
going to make me very much money,
I want my artwork to be accessible,
I want it,
I don't want it to be unreasonable and
attainable for people to be able to
purchase. So I, I need to
hire a business person.
I feel like I want to,
I want a little of both.
I think that creating tiers of work
that you could sell for different prices
helps to, to make things that
are accessible and um, you know,
there you have bigger ideas that a lot
of my work is installation artwork too.
So there's never like really, I
don't really intend on, it's a,
it's a temporary installation
and exist for that point in time.
So sales a lot of times aren't really,
the driving force is more like,
how can I complete this idea? Um, I,
I just moved back to Los Angeles after
living away for six years. And, um,
this past year that I've been back,
I've really been like forced to think
the people in the friends that I've met
are really made me think a lot about
pricing. And I was sort of a living in,
I feel like my own little dream world
of I just want to do the idea, man.
I'm just trying to get this idea out
there. The cash wasn't even about it.
It wasn't an in, that's the kind of the
struggling part. So that's why I teach
for Leo.
That's one of the reasons why I teach it.
I know that.
So I can have that,
that freeness to be able to like create
what I want to create and not be driven
by the price, but it's a,
it's a struggling game of
back and forth. And you know,
Yolanda is very established and,
and has a lot of years and I think that,
I hope one day to kind of get to a level
where I can be a lot more demanding
with it too. Um, but I also think, uh, it,
there's a line too about where you want
to be open and have people find you and
get to know you and,
and create that relationship through
being a little more accessible. Um,
yeah, it's difficult. It's very difficult.
I think as far as accessibility.
If somebody comes into the studio and
they really want a piece instead of
lowering the price, you know,
it's a small piece or something,
I'll just give it to them.
Okay.
You're like, I got payment plans. No, no.
[inaudible] I just say take it,
take it. If you want it, take it.
Yeah.
But, but, um, and then there's also like,
I have a watercolor series. It's really,
really reasonable for my work and, but
some of the paintings now, you know,
when I was your guys's age, I would paint
five, six, seven, 10 paintings in a week.
It was
now been on [inaudible] shoulder,
but now,
you know,
once a month, it's just, it's, you
know, it's closed down, but it,
but that's just where I'm at. You know,
that's his, that's this with 30 years of,
of the process is taking me and
I have to be accepting of that.
I'm not 25 anymore, you know, but, um,
anytime you need you, you want to come
over and talk, you know, we'll talk.
I'm there.
I'm open to that.
Any other questions?
Okay.
So I'm going to end with one last
one since. Any other questions? Um,
so we have 'em back to the
next generation. I'd love,
there's a ton of people who
not only are digital natives,
right, they don't know anything
else but the online world,
but also are really intrigued or really
want to explore art as part of who they
are.
Maybe it's their career as part of their,
what advice can you give them for this
next generation of artists? You know,
I always believe that can just
have technology, can just have art.
I think the combination works really
nicely now, especially now with steam,
right? Where you can do both. Um, what,
what advice can you give the next
generation of people or kids who want to
pursue art?
Okay.
I think just, just, it's just the old
classic, you know, follow your dream.
But now the dream is very large
and vast with, with the Internet.
Um,
and I think it's amazing for them to
have that accessibility to the Internet.
But I also think that the classic way
of learning art is very important.
So I think if there's a way to have
the classic way of learning art,
which is pencil, charcoal
still life, you know, um,
and then transfer that into the internet,
you know,
and combine it and incorporate
it and collaborate with it.
I think that's the fascinating part of
the new art we're going to be seeing, um,
in the future.
You know,
know where you come from.
Continue to be curious,
explore and just continue to ask
questions like within your own work.
Definitely. Nice. Um,
I dunno, I, I, I've thought about
this question a few different ways.
There's a lot of artists now who
solely exist on social media,
like their main venues are on social
media and they have a really hard time
doing the classic stuff.
You know, the nap again,
like I'm already got this many followers
and they're all, you know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's a different way of thinking,
but I think that's the challenge of how
the classic and the traditional still
engage that newer age because they found
ways to bypass a lot of the traditional
stuff. Why do I need to learn how
to draw the figure if I'm doing,
you know,
um,
specific performances and random spots
in la and I'm getting, uh, you know,
commissions and they're getting
paid for doing it. So it's,
it's the challenge that I think that the
institution hasn't quite yet led up to
learning how to teach those students how
to keep up with it all because they're
struggling with keeping up with
that new technology. Um, I,
I think too, that I remember
being a student and that this the,
the mode of thinking being like concept,
concept,
concept and those things are really
amazing. Um, you need, if you're,
if you're wanting to be an artist,
there's different types of artists.
Some people just paint in their basements
and never expose it to the public.
It's about that moment
that they're creating.
And it's not really about
sharing it with everybody.
Some other people have the yearning
to want to share it out in the public.
And it's about that communication,
the way that people perceive
it in a public space.
And that's what drives that force.
So I don't know that would have like
one piece of advice for artists.
It would be like, you know, what's your,
what's your main goal for this? You know?
Um,
yeah,
it's like stem is huge right now
in schools and you hear like,
I'm looking for jobs all the time and
they want to know how you can incorporate
stem into your curriculum. And a,
I think that accelerating lead,
it's more important because the schools
have stripped away like a lot of those
artists and creatives out of the school,
but they want to bring it on on again as
an educational component to teach them,
to teach them science,
to teach them all these other things.
But where can art exist just for
art? Like white, when you're a kid,
you think you're thinking about concept.
No,
you're remembering that fun part of why
you want to make art of what it is to
create. And it's important not to
lose that were so strained, I think,
to have this greater, bigger
social message. And those
things are very important,
but there should also still live a space
where you can just be free to create
just because, and you may
not know why, but it, it, it,
you need to have that happen at the same
time that other people are more driven
by that message. So to have both
existing simultaneously, I think,
and not knock people down for having a
different way of thinking about it or
working with it.
Yeah.
That's great.
I agree completely.
I think there's a space for
both also separately. Yeah.
And together. Why not? Yeah.
Again, thank you so, so
much. You've been wonderful.
Thank you for sharing such beautiful
personal stories for allowing us to have
and share your beautiful work
right here in our halls. Um,
and just for being here today.
Thank you. Thank you. Ladies.